I first started with photography on a
college road trip with my dad and I took
this picture and I remember looking at
the back of my camera and just being
like this is it this is what I'm gonna
do for the rest of my life my name is
Sophia Jaramillo I'm a National
Geographic photographer and Explorer I
felt like I grew up between two worlds
kind of in the middle not knowing where
to land and I'm a bridge between two
cultures and I try to see the beauty in
that in 2018 I moved to Jackson Hole to
pursue my dream of becoming an adventure
photographer and pretty quickly I
realized that there was an issue with
representation and so today I'm kind of
trying to change the narrative by
creating those images one that comes to
mind right off the bat was a profile
piece on a Latina woman who works for
the national parks here that photo is
saying we are here we deserve to be here
and you are welcome right now the
stories that I'm most interested in are
the stories that combine some of the
most important issues of our time social
justice is climate Justice the more
people we can welcome into the outdoors
the more tools we have and ideas we have
to fight climate change
[Music]